[Musica]
Peretto cosa è successo
sull'albero oggi nuovissima Challenge
nascondino in cui chi Vincerà Vincerà il
mio nuovissimo libro La città stregata
che è ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie e onl se ancora non ce l'avete
correte a prenderlo e la Challenge di
oggi sarà
Femmine contro
[Applauso]
vinceremo vinceremo
[Musica]
noi Io sono Anita e faccio parte del
team delle Femmine vinceremo noi il
libro La città stregata che ora è
custodito in questa teca perché è molto
prezioso non faremo vincere i maschi Io
sono Alice e sono del team delle femmine
e la vittoria è già nostra Io sono Ginny
come sapete del team delle femmine e
grazie a questo martello e alla mia
super capacità di trovare tutti
vinceremo noi Ciao a tutti io sono
Vitale e sto andando a mangiare sto
andando a nascondermi per prendere il
libro diita Stories ovviamente e
vinceremo noi vinceremo noi del team dei
maschi andiamo Ciao ragazzi io sono
Frank del team dei maschi e ora corro a
nascondermi perché molto modestamente lo
voglio vincere Io quel libro non voglio
essere battuto dalle femmine sarebbe
troppo un'umiliazione Io sono Manuele e
faccio parte del team dei maschi qui non
lo sa nessuno ma io sono un campione di
nascondino e oggi ve lo dimostrerò per
il primo round si nasconderà la squadra
numero due cioè i maschi dovranno
mimetizzarsi quindi si divideranno siete
pronti iniziamo subito a contare
via 1 2 tre Oh ragazzi Ragazzi dove
andiamo a nasconderci l no là
[Musica]
sì Eccomi non c'è posto migliore dove
nascondersi della cucina e in più in
cucina potrò anche mangiare Che bello
non vedo l'ora andiamo a
nasconderci non mi troverà mai qui Anzi
mi è venuta un'idea
Sono nascosto
benissimo Il tempo scorre dove mi
nascondo qua no mi vedo troppo Ho
un'idea qua non mi troveranno mai Sono
nascosto dentro la siepe con questa
tutina verde nessuno potrà trovarmi
perché mi nasconderò nell'erba e quindi
mi mimetiz ve l'ho detto che sono il
campione di nascondino andiamo
[Musica]
30 siamo pronti a trovare tutti i maschi
da che parte Andiamo Secondo voi eh di
là oppure di là Ho un'idea Dividiamoci
così avremo più possibilità di trovarli
hai ragione Sì andiamo Eccomi sono nel
posto preferito di Vitale la cucina sono
sicura che lo troverò qua
Oh no se fanita che sta
arrivando Ehi Vitale dove
[Musica]
sei
trovato non è nascosto qua Eppure mi era
[Musica]
sembrato
Vitale Ma
[Musica]
dov'è
Vitale ma cosa stai facendo dividendo il
panino con Merlino e praticamente mi ero
nascosto qui però Merlino voleva
mangiare allora abbiamo deciso di devi
darci un panino Beh mi dispiace Ti ho
trovato quindi hai perso e ora vado ad
aiutare le ragazze a trovare gli altri
due maschi Oh no mi ha trovato
basta Merlino non mi mangiare tutto il
panino Secondo me qualcuno si è nascosto
in quelle siepi e ho un modo per
trovarlo geniale Invece secondo il mio
intuito qualcuno si trova qui in zona
andiamo a trovarli Sì forza te in
femmine vai dove si saranno nascosti
vediamo se sono qua magari potrebbe
essere
sull'albero
bene ora Vi insegnerò un giochino e si
chiama trova la
talpa 1 2
Oh no sto martellando la siepe Speriamo
non mi
trovi e adesso il colpo
finale
3 Eccoli Li abbiamo
trovati stupido mi
respiro Ma sei stupido ma Frank ma Comè
possibile
V
[Musica]
per il nostro round abbiamo preparato
una trappola per i maschi è perfetto sì
eh sì sì sì non mangiar Mi raccomando
sono per i maschi questi è una trappola
per distrarli abbiamo riempito il piatto
di
delti e questo lo lasciamo
qua
SH e ora andiamo a nasconderci forza
andiamo adesso tocca a noi dobbiamo
riscattarci haii capito sì e ce la
faremo alla grande da iniziamo a contare
Camo noi questo round iniziamo a contare
dai sì andate a nascondervi voi 1 2 3 4
io mi nascondo qua dietro a questo
albero gigante Ehi Ma voi avete cliccato
mi piace cliccate mi piace se fate parte
del team delle Femmine Se invece fate
parte del del team dei maschi lasciate
un commento qua
sotto con questo mio travestimento da
manichino non riusciranno mai a
trovarmi Speriamo di non muovermi
troppo devo trovare un posto per
nascondermi dobbiamo vincere va bene
dai sono sicura che non mi troveranno
mai
[Applauso]
Allora piano piano piano ma che piano
piano piano trovarle tu vai di là Io
vado di là Bravo Ok andiamo via dove
devo andare io non mi ricordo più forse
di qua il mio istinto mi dice che
qualcuno è uscito di casa oh no si sta
avvicinando e quindi Essendo io il
campione di nascondino devo per forza
trovarne almeno una Allora vediamo dove
può essere sotto il vaso no dietro la
siepe No una ragazza non si
nasconderebbe mai dietro la siepe forse
dietro qualche albero vediamo un
po' si sta avvicinando sempre di più mi
sa che mi ha
scoperta Mamma mia ma doveo possono
essersi cacciate
queste qua
no qua no
[Musica]
Chissà dove si saranno
cacciate bella questa
libreria molto bella anche questa Ma
questo manichino è super realistico
adesso lo abbellisco
io allora questo manichino riuscirà a
tenere
questa m e riuscirà anche a tenere
queste
interessante vediamo un
[Musica]
po' dove si saranno cacciate noi del
team dei maschi dobbiamo vincere il
libro di
[Musica]
Anita non ci posso credere è così
semplice è proprio qui sicuramente sotto
questo pupazzo ci sarà nascosto qualcuno
controlliamo Ma non ci posso credere Non
c'è nessuno
[Musica]
qui lì o lì o lì forse lì andiamo a
vedere Mi è venuta un'idea ma anche
secondo voi questo manichino semb sembra
Alice Uffa mi hai trovata E che cavolo
pensavo di essere un manichino
Perfetto cosa è successo ma almeno mi
sta
[Musica]
bene L'ho trovata L'ho trovata
ah
Ma questo è Frank Forse le ha trovate
tutte lui andiamo a
controllare l'avete sentito questo
sembrava la voce di Frank forse ha
trovato tutte le altre abbiamo vinto
Sì C'è mancato poco Ciao sono l'emoji di
Anita sono qua per ricordarvi che è
appena uscito il mio nuovo libro La
città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito mi sono salvata Ma
perché corso dentro Deo andare a
controllare Che
meraviglia Frank Frank Che cosa è
successo le hai trovate Sì le hai
trovate Ehi che succede Ragazzi ho
trovato le dolci Grande Frank bravissimo
Che cosa c'hai in
testa effettivamente eri un po' strano
ragazzi per
noi
Grande
Ehi avete smesso di
cercarci Quindi abbiamo vinto
noi siete caduti nella nostra trappola
quindi ha vinto il team femmine possiamo
finalmente prendere il libro La città
stregata è nostro e se lo volete anche
voi correte in libreria o prendetelo in
libreria on è ora disponibile la città
stregata glies del mistero
no Lo volevamo noi il libro perché siamo
così stupidi perché sono ingannato col
cibo è normale Esatto Non vale questo è
un colpo basso non va bene Vabbè
Guardate il lato positivo almeno ci
abbiamo riempito la pancia è vero ancora
doviamo mangiare
[Musica]
via
C